blain merci de ce président monsieur le
premier ministre
depuis quatre ans cette majorité a pris
un certain nombre de funestes décision
par exemple sourds aux conseils de bon
sens vous avez décidé de chasser les
maires de l'assemblée nationale en effet
en 2017
dans moins de 400 jours ne pourront pas
être candidats aux législatives
ceux qui sont déchus de leurs droits
civiques
c'est à dire les assassins les voleurs
et les escrocs et les 36000 maires de
france autre exemple là aussi sourd aux
mises en garde le président de la
république et le gouvernement
ces vivres et les dotations du par
l'état aux communes dans des proportions
extravagantes
le résultat ne s'est pas fait attendre
mis au pied du mur les maires n'ont pas
eu le choix
les investissements des communes
pourtant indispensables ont régressé
mettant en difficulté toutes les
entreprises de travaux publics
dans quelques jours le président de la
république va se rendre au salon des
maires d'ici là
pouvez vous monsieur le premier ministre
lui dire que lui président doit
absolument annoncé au maire qu'il recule
et qu'il renonce à ponctionner une fois
encore les finances communales
il a fait fausse route soit mais il est
encore temps pour lui de faire amende
honorable
chacun ici connaît le célèbre préceptes
latin
pcar et idem bis à haute vitesse à 110
est c'est pas celui que vous attendiez
je vous le traduis commettre deux fois
la même faute n'est pas le fait d'un
homme sage dit le bien à madame la
ministre de l'éducation line à part ça
pousse à mes yeux le forum
manuel valls le député nous avons je
crois apprécié la la modération de vaud
de vos mots aussi monsieur jacob je
réponds aux députés de vos groupes et
avec immensément de plaisir et la
réponse va être courte premièrement
mettez vous d'accord
d'abord avec les candidats aux primaires
de votre formation politique concernant
les collectivités territoriales est
expliquée au congrès des maires comment
vous allez faire si vous arrivez au
pouvoir et soyez respectueux d'ailleurs
du choix du peuple français
l'élection a lieu dans un an et en
général tous les pronostics
un an avant une élection présidentielle
au fait fausse route en tout cas c'est
le respect du peuple français que
d'attendre son choix avant déjà de tirer
des plans sur la comète mais vous allez
expliquer à l'occasion du congrès des
maires
comment il y a une cohérence entre la
question que vous venez de poser et la
volonté de faire 100 milliards
d'économies alors que nous savons que
cela va concerner l'éducation nationale
la police la gendarmerie l'hôpital et
les collectivités territoriales
comment les collectivités territoriales
vont pouvoir fonctionner alors que des
candidats de votre formation politique
explique qu'il faut des dizaines de
milliers de postes de fonctionnaires et
notamment de la fonction publique
territoriale en moins alors que vous
proposez vous même 10 à 15 milliards
supplémentaires de ponction sur les
collectivités territoriales
alors puisque vous voulez de l'éthique
de la responsabilité et de la vérité
face aux français mettez vous d'accord
d'abord avec vos candidats avant de
venir critiquer le gouvernement sur
cette question là et deuxième réponse
monsieur le député oui nous assumons et
je pense que c'était un engagement pris
devant les français d'avoir fait voter
le non cumul des mandats c'est une
décision attendue par les français est
l'un de vos candidats mans devant les
français quand il explique qu'il va
revenir sur cette réforme
ces deux réformes qui interdira à part
2010 est le cumul entre l'exécutif et
âme aux parlementaires un membre de
l'assemblée nationale ou du sénat et une
réforme importante
il ne sert à rien de la combe accès
rétrograde la modernité aujourd'hui elle
va dans ce sens merci monsieur le
premier ministre la balle